hi everybody I'm Nick Gillespie and I am
the editor in chief of reason calm and
reason TV and I'm joined by Katherine
mangu Ward the editor of Reason magazine
current editor of Reason magazine and
Marty Zupan who was the editor of Reason
magazine in the 1980s we are not joined
by Matt Welch or Virginia pastoral or
Bob Poole other editors who could make
it but I think we can pick up for them
what we're going to talk about today is
reason and libertarianism in the age of
Trump and I also would ask for a big
round of applause because this is also a
live taping of the reason podcast with
so where this will be going up in a
couple days so let let people know
you're here in the in the region podcast
player
[Applause]
alright alright come on mutt that's
enough all right a little bit so just
very briefly before what we're gonna do
is we're gonna talk about the issues
that were kind of big when we were
editing the magazine I guess mostly you
know in the distant past myself I was
editor from 2000 to 2008 beginning of
2008 Marty as I said was in the 80s
Kathryn became the editor nice five
minutes ago five minutes ago okay [ __ ]
she's already made the magazine look
much better than it has in a long time
so more power to her
but reason was founded as a monthly
magazine of free minds and free markets
in 1968 our website went live in 1994
the video reason TV video platform went
live in 2007 and the podcast in 2016
about four or five months ago
we've always been you know I was going
to use the term nonpartisan but we're
really unimportant because we you know
like seven up the unco Lahui just were
we're working on a totally different
frequency but we're very engaged we're
independent we're pre-political the idea
of libertarian with a small L is that
it's an attitude a temperament a
direction a default setting that informs
your political engagements but it
actually exists before them I think and
we're journalistic we're we're a
magazine of ideas but were also a
magazine of journalism and as Lanny
Friedlander the founder of Reason
magazine who passed away a few years ago
put it in the first issue we try to
trade in logic not legends where are a
source of libertarian news including
stories that are uncovered we were on
the criminal-justice beat and talking
about things like over-policing of black
and minority areas of civil asset
forfeiture reform long before other
people were so we're bringing stories
that weren't being covered by the press
but then we also bring a libertarian
point of view on big news so you know if
you want to know what the libertarian
kind of take or a strong libertarian
analysis on immigration on draw
policy on things that are in the news on
trade you got a reason we're a source of
community for libertarians we host intra
movement debates to kind of bring our
best ideas out make them sharper and
also learn how to hate people because
they disagree with you on one percent of
one issue it's a very you know it's the
one thing that I think that makes us
human right as libertarians
and then we are also we do outreach and
conversion we reach out to other
journalists and give them stories or a
way of thinking about the world which is
helpful and we also try to help build
the next generation of libertarians of
whatever age and with that is kind of a
background we're going to Marty is going
to talk first there's a couple of covers
from her tenure one of them is about and
I believe that's from about 1982 the one
Vermont's unknown 84 84 and then one
about corporate welfare in Texas but
talk a little bit about Marty what you
know what we're kind of the signature
issues and ideas that you were grappling
with in the 80s and have they carried
forward into contemporary debates it was
an amazing opportunity to be the editor
of reason from or to be at reason from
1979 to 1989 Ronald Reagan was the
president during most of that era he's
ancient history to most of you I guess
but you know Reagan's legacy and so
there was a real flowering of
libertarian and free market ideas during
that time but of course it was mixed
with a lot of not libertarian and not
free market ideas so there was plenty of
work for us to do interestingly during
that decade there were also increasing
changes and liberalisation --zz behind
the Iron Curtain culminating by the end
of that decade in the fall of the Berlin
Wall and it was it was cool to be an
observer of that especially for somebody
who grew up in that era of communism
yeah I mean
in say 79 when you when you started
working reason did you have any inkling
you know that the Berlin wall would be
collapsing no it was it was utterly
surprising although one of my favorite
editorials that are ever wrote which was
in the first reason volume was in 1988
and I it was titled 1988 year of Hope
because by that time you could see that
there was a very real possibility that
the wall was going to fall and it was
all going to crumble so it was cool to
be there but some of the issues that
were front and center for us at reason
in those days continue to be and the the
cover of that January 1984 issue on
vouchers which was the first issue of
which I was actually the editor-in-chief
that if she was still with us right come
think about the utter panic over the
nomination of DeVos partly because
heavens she might want more choice for
school for kids in schools and so that
issue is still with us and so and other
issues have changed the details but not
in the essentials so for example we did
a lot of work on regulation government
regulation and most of you are too young
to remember when the airlines were
wholly regulated by the government
prices entry amenities on the on the
airplanes everything was regulated and
likewise trucking interstate trucking
railroads whole industries regulated by
the government those the agencies that
regulated those industries have been
deep-sixed gone completely gone but
imagine today in fact you don't have to
imagine it if anybody suggests canning
the Department of Education for example
that's considered like a third rail
right so so there was some progress on
the other hand today we have health and
safety regulations across a whole swath
of our lives so those industry
regulators have gone away but instead we
have
the EPA and the Consumer Product Safety
Commission and etc etc and the newest
one is perhaps Elizabeth Warren's
favorite the Financial Protection Bureau
right always well named right always so
Orwellian named perhaps it's you know
one of the if you go back and have
reasoned calm you can scroll through all
of the old issues the covers if you're a
subscriber and you should subscribe to
Reason magazine for $15 a year you
should subscribe of course to the reason
podcasts at iTunes but you had a ton of
issues where they were people in fish
bowls saying how did I get here and it
was all about these new petty regulation
consumer products and safety issues it
seems right I like to think that reason
played a part in the deregulation that
did happen because from the beginning
through the 70s and through the 80s
reason was publishing scholars and
experts arguing against regulation
particularly at the federal level
long before think tanks were well
established in DC and then eventually in
all the states around the country so
reason played a vital role there while
we have all these new regulatory
agencies replace our regulations
replacing old ones there there has on
the other hand been enormous progress on
personal liberties in a relatively short
period of time and on these issues in
the 80s reason was often like a voice in
the wilderness but today we have person
a freedom lays a fair approach pretty
much across the board on personal
liberties we actually ran articles and
reason arguing against serious proposals
to have the feds regulate pop the
content of popular music that that's
gone away that issue has gone away today
music all kinds of music is free in more
ways than one on the Internet and this
is a case as in so many others where
technological change
has undercut the ability of government
to exercise command and control party
are you gonna freestyle rap some filthy
lyrics right now are you going to work I
guess we'll leave that so bottom line is
is I is to remember that change is
possible and it often isn't a matter of
defeating or or taking back government
regulation and government intervention
in our lives but often it is bubbling up
from in society and we should then we
should celebrate that and work for that
as well Thank You Marnie I'm gonna talk
about some of my issues and you know by
the way this is also I'm sure that you
ran because we still may do this I don't
know if the next issue of Katherine's
reason is gonna be about how we can
finally get rid of the post office but I
know whatever we were all over that when
I started working everything in 1993 and
one of the first pieces that I got I had
published in the magazine was about how
it was something like fax machines were
eroding the horrible government monopoly
on first-class mail and I have how many
of you know what a fax machine is or has
ever used that because it's like within
a decade the fax was gone and you know
and and I think you're right that a lot
of times technology just blows things up
in terms of you know when we think of
some you know taxi Commission's were
more local entities but they were
controlling things
uber has you know upended that although
not I mean there's a bitter fight going
on for so I was editor-in-chief I took
over in 2000 and the two covers here
that are kind of interesting exemplify
two of the major themes which I think
are very much still with us the first
one the the brown cover with the big
brother is watching you kind of icon
there was the first issue that we
published after the 9/11
tax and we talked about the Patriot Act
had been signed already etc and we
talked about how the war on terror
which Donald Rumsfeld who thankfully
most of us have completely forgotten
about had talked about how the war on
terror was going to be like the Cold War
and there was a palpable sense after the
collapse of the Soviet Union in the end
of communism you know a lot of people
were kind of nostalgic for that great
Twilight battle between good and evil
between the free world and the Communist
world and people in the Bush
administration were clearly looking for
something like that and they found it in
talking about the global war on terror
and as an Islamic Jihad and we said you
know the main casualty are going to be
people in countries that we bomb and we
occupy and you know we're still bombing
and still occupying countries based on
that but also in a massive assault on
civil liberties which stays with us and
that you know this for libertarians it
is a mix of you know a foreign policy
critique which has not been - which was
not taken seriously by other
right-wingers or left wingers for most
of the Cold War there was very much of a
consensus that if you've read Robert
Heinlein Starship Troopers a kind of
idea that like we have to be anywhere
the bugs might be because if they get
something even if it's a useless piece
of [ __ ] asteroid somewhere out you know
beyond the the Alpha Centauri or
whatever we've got to be there because
otherwise they'll have it that was
American foreign policy consensus and
and the libertarian critique of that was
you know maybe there are better ways to
win people to freedom and to free people
and it turns out you know the the end of
the Cold War helped prove that with very
few exceptions in Eastern Europe it was
peaceful revolutions and as Marty was
talking about it was the ground up the
Berlin Wall fall the Berlin Wall didn't
collapse on its own it was pulled down
by East Germans and so we're still in
this battle because Donald Trump and I
think Rand Paul was saying it and it was
right Donald Trump seemed to be more of
an
of a non-interventionist or a smart
interventionist certainly than Hillary
Clinton so far it's not working out that
way but that's a major you know
battleground talking about foreign
policy and how America can intervene in
the world
through markets through trade through
Commerce in a way to make it free or
rather than you know bombing people back
to the Stone Age and looking at civil
liberties being squeezed in America the
other issue
this says they know where you live this
came out of 2004 2006 it was the very
first mass-produced individualised
magazine ever printed we use
cutting-edge technology and one of our
longtime readers and a contributor to
Reason foundation the nonprofit that
publishes us does it direct mail catalog
stuff and he had learned how to
personalize things so we printed up
45,000 magazines that went to
subscribers that show their house on the
cover that had four pages of material
that was specifically key to their
congressional district to their county
to their congressional district County
and one other thing but it was we we
were able the ads were also personalized
than that and that was another big theme
of one of the things reason talks about
is that you know we're trying to get
beyond politics we believe in free minds
at free markets we believe that the most
interesting parts of life should exist
beyond politics which in needs consensus
which we're 51% of the people can make
49 percent of the people live the way
they want to and individualization and
personalization which is very much in
accord with most libertarian principles
we're seeing that in all aspects of our
life we see that in our personal lives
and our business lives in our culinary
lives everywhere that government does
not have a strong purchase and hopefully
through school vouchers and whatnot
we'll actually be able to see that in
education hopefully if we get to a
market system in health care and
retirement we'll also see people be able
to individualize and personal
those very important parts of their
lives the same ways they do the romantic
lives the same way they do you know when
you get a cup of coffee or you go into a
you know a restaurant with one of those
great new soda machines where you can
literally make an infinite number of
sweet drinks that will probably give you
cancer and rot your teeth out so those
are kind of two of the big issues that
that define my tenure at reason and I
think those are still with us both the
good and the bad and Katherine why don't
you take a swig of water and and sex it
looks like yeah so I'm obviously the the
new editor-in-chief the magazine you can
sort of think of Nicolas B's tenure and
and Matt Welsh's tenure after him as an
extension it was sort of a sex drugs and
rock and roll overlay on the magazine
I'm thinking my tenure is going to be a
little more sex drugs and robots so if
you guys are at that drop me a line this
issue which went out to subscribers
today you can pick up your copy on the
reason table it's it is a sex issue I'm
sorry to tell you though that it is like
reasons boner killer issue basically
because it's all bad news I don't know
how it happened exactly I was like let's
do a sexy issue it'll be fun and then it
was like everyone's in jail just so
we've this great cover story by
elizabeth nolan brown that's about the
operation cross country which is this
huge national effort to catch child sex
traffickers which seems to actually just
basically be a big dumb vice bust we
also have taken solemn on this sort of
unconstitutional irregularities of the
way that we deal with people who have
who are caught with child pornography
we have Deirdre McCloskey who writes
about her experience transitioning and
being committed by various actors of the
state for for her personal choices like
it's just so depressing
I'm very sorry cuz it does it come with
Viagra or some there at least the coupon
weed personalized daily guessing but I'm
really excited about bringing reason in
obviously we will be covering Donald
Trump the issue before this one we were
sort of flirting with various
terminology for him I'm not gonna call
him a fascist today but like a good
reason editor I reserve the right to
drop the f-bomb everywhere in anywhere
so let's just give it a minute
we'll see for now I'm liking corporate
authoritarian maybe I don't know you
guys shouldn't you should let me know
what you think about that one too I
started out as an Internet reason so for
those of you that are thinking about
slogging through some kind of summer
internship you know sometimes it pays
off pretty well
that summer I spent what felt like the
entire summer transcribing an interview
with this New Mexico Governor who was
really amazing you should probably have
a wider audience and then I became
editor of Reason magazine and everyone
was couldn't shut up about Gary Johnson
so these things come full circle I guess
but I am I'm really looking forward to
helming the nation's foremost
libertarian publication there's probably
somebody here that would like fight me
for that title right but I think we I
think we deserve it
and I think we're gonna we're gonna talk
a little bit about Trump yes we've been
to cheer so far about yeah so yes so
that's kind of backstory and bringing us
up to the current moment but now
libertarians in the age of Donald Trump
this is the other part you know and and
it I think how many of you are
optimistic about Donald Trump okay yeah
I I think I see a make America great oh
great again hat or is it alright yeah
but it's you know Marty let's talk about
the libertarians in the age of Trump
what is your biggest concern and it's
it's not just Donald Trump I mean we are
in a moment of American politics of
political life very polarized people are
dropping out of the Republican and
Democratic Party which I find you know a
good thing but what what are your
biggest concerns about Trump well I'm
gonna go straight to the metal level and
my biggest concern is that you know
Trump bills himself as a man of action
and he's going in there and doing a lot
of executive action on things and many
of the things that he has a promise to
radically transform to really upset in
in government we would like to see
radically transformed and upset right
but my fear is that if it comes through
strong men government rather than under
rule of law I think we lose we lose
because it's not about principles it's
not it's not tenable and sustainable and
and so that's my that's my biggest fear
fortunately I think we have something to
up to stand up against that so I'm
encouraged here by these the breadth and
depth of the intellectual libertarian
movement I'm I'm the person long in
tooth here so I you know I've been
observing this I said to somebody
thinking about this when I was started
out at reason you basically that was all
the libertarians in the country yeah
just about
I mean I'm exactly probably just saying
whatever whatever just get rid of my
next paycheck but but that that many
people but now there are reason has
played a role in building the the
intellectual substance the organization
I have worked out since leaving reason
for the last 28 years the Institute for
Humane studies that's our specialty to
convey these ideas and find people who
are interested in them and build up
their strength and build an intellectual
movement you are both alumni of IHS
programs
the founders of SFL for alumni of IHS
programs there are now nearly 2,000
professors teaching at over 900 colleges
and universities who are alumni of IHS
programs our alums are throughout the
think tanks and so on and and this is
what matters and students for Liberty is
now playing its part in bringing new
young people into this fold so we have
to fight bad ideas with good ideas and
that's the that's the opportunity but
the fear is that the the impulse to
action overtakes you know just very
briefly to follow up on that - I said a
load of David beause of the Cato
Institute who's out there somewhere and
a little while ago he looked at how the
according to Gallup poll results that
out of the four ways that Gallup slices
up Americans ideological II libertarians
for the first time are the biggest chunk
there's 27% that kind of our considered
libertarian about 26 or 25% conservative
I forget it was like 23 or 22 percent
liberal and about 15 percent populist so
you know this is this is your guys time
to go out there the students for Liberty
to really you will be fighting the
battle of ideas and whatnot we're
counting on you yeah trust me yeah cuz
it's like you know at least Marty and I
are we're not yeah we want to take it
easy but Kathryn what about you what are
your biggest fears for the Euro of
trauma yeah I think it's really simple
free movement of people and goods across
borders is an incredibly important
and Trump is not into either of those
things as far as I can tell and that's
that's something that that's what keeps
me awake nights I mean I want I want
everyone who wants to come here to be
able to come I want everyone who wants
to sell us stuff to be able to sell us
stuff I want everyone who wants to leave
here to be able to leave and I want
everything we make to be able to sell to
the entire world it shouldn't be hard
apparently it is and reason is going to
just be following every single freaking
time Trump screws that up I think
something that kind of builds on or
follows from what both Marty and Kathryn
had said for me it's it's the kind of
classical liberal ideas of
cosmopolitanism and pluralism and
tolerance Trump is not a tolerant person
we know that right and and he does not
seem to care much about pluralism he
doesn't have respect for different ways
of living different ways of doing things
he writes off whole populations you know
Mexicans are you know if they're if
they're desperate enough to come here to
work and do jobs that we don't want to
do they're rapists and drug dealers and
you know and I love that when he opened
this was like how he announced he was
going to be President some of them I
assume are good people you know it's
like thanks but it's not just Trump and
it's not just Republicans like Jeff
Sessions who is anti-immigrant or
conservative groups like National Review
who are saying now that your position on
immigration is for conservatives what
abortion used to be you have to be
anti-immigration in order to be a
conservative that's not cosmopolitanism
it's disturbing and it's something we
need to fight on the left they have
their own version you know they're not
interested in tolerance or pluralism
this is the problem with things like
speech codes on college campuses we're
saying everybody who disagrees with you
is not merely misguided but is actually
evil or should be punched one of our
writers write up a piece about how you
know under the headline well that didn't
take long and it's like it's okay to
punch Nazis and also white liberty white
male libertarians and you know I take
that one a little
yeah yeah I take that and that one a
little personally but but we're seeing
in this moment where we have remnants of
the the right and the left who are
commanding fewer and fewer people's
Allegiance they're getting worse and
worse and they're intolerant they're
anti pluralistic in different ways and
that's my big fear we are going to stop
now we've been told we don't have time
for questions but because this has been
a live taping of the reason podcast I
would appreciate it if everybody could
cheer so they know we're not just making
this up
[Applause]
okay well thank you thank you so much
and I want to especially I want to thank
everybody at students for liberty but
also Marty Zupan of IHS thanks Marty so
much
Katherine manga ward of reason so much
for reason I'm Nicole sp
please subscribe to the reason podcasts
at iTunes and look for us at recent calm
thanks again so much
[Applause]